purpose i i i don't even i i wrestle
with that all the time i was like what's
your purpose
you know try to be a good person try to
give back try to help those that are in
need try to
um
but do something that makes you feel
good altruistically you know what i mean
yeah and i i don't i still am unsure of
my purpose
maybe my purpose i'm already living my
purpose doing this podcast helping
people maybe that's part of my purpose i
don't know there's got to be something
bigger what's yours do you feel like you
have purpose
well
yeah i mean i think this is
where
i think where this is where god comes
into and i think the main issue with god
is that how people define god so if you
define god as like
a daddy man male figure who's powerful
kind of gazing down on us and it's like
ryan was good today michael was bad
today
that kind of god i'm not talking about
but if i if you're talking about like
the you know the the the creative power
of the cosmos that is within us and
without us and flows through everything
and
uh
gives a kind of greater purpose and our
souls are connected to that so our
bodies will drop away but we'll continue
into some other plane of existence
onwards toward this all-powerful
you know cosmic energy so
if
when i feel
good is when i feel aligned with that
energy whatever that is i it's it's
obviously it's hard to describe but it's
more of a feeling than anything else but
i i liken it like to a sailboat where
like you want to get over to catalina
but the wind's blowing that way so you
have to kind of tack
but but you kind of like if you feel the
wind in your sails
then maybe you're headed in the right
direction and that's it's a it's an
ineffable thing the wind in the cosmic
wind in your sails so
i try and be in that like is it does
this feel like
i'm being taken in some kind of right
direction you know so one of the things
i'm doing right now is i'm writing a
book on spirituality which is obviously
a passion of mine
and
which is a weird thing for a
comedic character actor from a sitcom to
be writing a book on spirituality might
be the first time ever but it feels
right it feels like oh this is a good
thing this is something i should be
doing now
this is uh that's great uh so that does
feel good my wife and i have a
non-profit in haiti called a haiti that
educates girls in rural haiti when i do
the work on that i
you know i myself out as dwight
like i do these in fact there's a thing
on prizeo.com right now where i i'm
going to give an office tour through the
san fernando valley of like our
locations oh yeah i saw that on
instagram right yeah i just i just
posted it uh today it just launched um
and
and then i take all that money and then
i give it over to these programs that
are educating girls who can't read you
know essentially so that gives you
purpose that feels good it just feels
good it's like i'm never gonna be like
if i do something like cameo or
something like that i'll take that i'll
i'll do i'll do those annoying videos
but i'm gonna send the money off to